[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
39th episode of dirty chest tricks in
this episode I am going to demonstrate a
tricky line in the ratio ponine against
one of the most popular set up by black
which is awfully used by all level of
chess players including super
grandmasters with the use of online
database as a real player if you find
out that your opponent is regularly
employing this lines then this video
provides you a great secret weapon for
the tournament practice the opening
arises after the following order Knight
to f3 defy c4 c6 g3 Knight to f6 and
Bishop to g2 now as I highlighted over
here in the majority of case black has
this two popular choices amongst them d
captures C fool now or any early stage
of the opening is outside the scope of
this video because we are going to
concentrate on the move Bishop to g4
however I do recommend that you go
through the opening manual and find out
a good line against it okay Bishop to g4
so the idea is very simple black wants
to take out this bishop before he closed
the pawn chain with c6 and in some lines
black can sacrifice this mission and get
a very solid position here I recommend
that you continue with Knight to e5
attacking the bishop and if white can
get that bishop without any compensation
then in a long run black is going to
suffer for it
so accordingly black has to preserve his
LightSquared bishop there are two
popular choices from here amongst them
if your opponent continued with Bishop
to e6 then I have attached a model game
in the PGN which will give you a great
idea how to handle such a position but
in majority of the cases black continued
with Bishop to a5 as it looks more
natural but in fact black has
straightaway enter into the white tricky
camp the tricky business start with C
captures define C captures B Phi and now
this very cunning move Knight to c3 now
as I have highlighted over here he six
is one of the most popular choice by
black and that we are going to see in
detail however if you opponent continue
with Knight B to d7 or Queen to c7 then
d4 is a very strong reply and apart from
it black and also made to blunder moves
which can give white a decisive
advantage for example if you open and
continues with d4 which again looks very
natural in this position but after that
blackest instantly losing with Queen to
b3 so white is attacking to sport and
most important is what is threatening
Queen f7 checkmate something which black
has to defend immediately and the good
way to defend it is to play a six but
after that following sequence will
happen on the ball Queen captures b7
Knight B to d7 Knight captures d7 Knight
captures d7 Queen captures a eight Queen
captures aid Bishop captures eight pawn
captures c3 and pawn captures c3 and
just within 13 moves of the game white
emerged with an exchange and a to pawn
advantage
the second move Knight to c6 is not good
either because after the simple capture
on c6 in pawn captures in the long run
this backward C pawn is going to give a
great headache to the black camper so
considering all these options here
the obvious choice for the black is to
play a six consolidate his position and
what can be the wrong well in chess some
positions are very deceptive and this is
one of the case because after Wyatt's
next reply g4 white is winning in all
lines first important point black cannot
take this pawn twice for example if
Knight captures g4 Knight captures g4
and Bishop captures g4 which happen in
one of my blitz game we're here
the simplest replies you deliver this
Queen check nab the piece and
comfortably win the game so that means
black has to move the bishop and the
only move left is Bishop to d6
and after that you already guessed it
right yup it's h4 hahaha
so White has a very simple thread to
play the move edge fire
trapping this mission and that means
black responds are very much limited as
I have shown black has tried these three
options and let's see each by turn the
first more I want to consider is Bishop
to d6 which is highest Lee played in
this position but after the Moody fall I
think black is in a serious trouble
black obviously cannot take this Knight
the simple reason is after pawn takes
Knight to d7 h5 Bishop to e4 and f3 that
black tower is going down
so that means black has to play either
at 6:00 or h5 and whenever this happens
on the board let's say at 6:00 first
then the golden rule you have to
remember is always take the bishop
immediately and after pawn takes you
heat out on the g6 square with Queen to
d3 King to f7 is forced and now comes
the aggressive tactics by white g5 okay
some moves are very much forcing pawn
takes pawn takes rook takes Bishop takes
and now it doesn't matter wherever this
Knight goes the following disaster will
happen boom ah ha ha ha so not only
white is a clear point up but blacking
is completely misplaced and we should
see what happens if you open it except
this piece sacrifice he captures defy
when after that white obtained the
winning advantage which Bishop captures
defy King to evade Queen to f3 King
cannot move as Queen to f7 is a
checkmate and if black blocked the check
with night then we have the simple move
Bishop captures b7 and white will get to
pieces
the third new black and try over here is
H Phi which is more natural but after
that our familiar sequence will happen
Knight captures g6 pawn captures g6 and
this time around we can play the move g5
first asking this night where he wants
to go there are two good locations for
the night
neither of them provide any satisfaction
result for black if Knight to g4 then
the simplest is you play Queen to d3
attacking on g6 King clip 7 and now I
think you already guessed it yup our
familiar sacrifice Knight captricity
fire he kept his defy Bishop captures
defy check King to e7 Bishop captures b7
Knight B to d7 and after the move Queen
to e4 white emerge with a clear exchange
and upon up I reached this position in
one of my rapid game against the 2100
rated opponent and hear my opponent
continue with Knight to g8 which looks
more logical as he can support the g6
pawn with Knight to e7 but anyways I
found the another swift target Bishop to
edge 3 if Queen to see it or d7 the
knight to defer is a deadly reply and if
Queen to e7 then e 4 is a very strong
reply in the game after a long
consideration my opponent continued with
King to f7 which at first sight looks
very safe but after the following
aggression evil attacking on defy kindly
note Knight to e7 is not a possibility
due to the simple Queen check and after
King to g8 and Bishop captures c6 black
position is completely collapsed so
that's why in the game my opponent here
continued with pawn captures ephone but
then I give him this rude shock
defy he desperately want to block the
position which ePHI but I'm afraid it's
not going to help him as after the move
Bishop Jack King to f8 simple move
Knight captures a fool and black is
completely defenseless
he tried Knight to e7 and after Queen
check he blocked the check with the
night but this doesn't solve the problem
as after Bishop captures f5 pawn
captures fr Queen captures fi and
wherever this King goes on the opposite
flank Queen will give the check for
example in the game black plays King to
e8
I played Queen to g6 check attacking
twice on d6 so my opponent plays King to
e7 which is close to resignation as
after Queen captures g7 check came to e8
and Knight to f6 by force black has to
give up the Queen and after Queen
captures f6 white can have all kind of
fun on the ball so even though Bishop to
d6 is one of the most popular choice by
black I think is highly inaccurate let's
look at the second reply by black h5 so
far whatever you have seen I think you
have a very good idea how to handle such
a positions okay in this game White has
delayed the capture on g6 but it doesn't
matter sooner or later this is going to
happen white plays the forcing move
first
that is G Phi asking Black Knight where
he wants to go and if he goes to the g4
then after Queen check
Knight to d7 Knight captures g6 pawn
captures g6 and Queen to c2 we have the
familiar terra-tory King to f7 and now
yup it's white captures d5 boom-boom
well black doesn't have any good option
he has to take it
but after that the simplest sequences
Bishop kept his defy check if King to e8
then Queen captures g6 and there's a
mate in two so black has to play King to
e7 and now we can simply give this check
if King to d6 then Bishop captures b7 is
a very strong reply so in this game
black plays Knight to e5 but after the
move d4 he simply resigned as his King
is stuck in the center his extra piece
is going to be lost and on top of
everything White has a two point
advantage
well how about Knight F to d7 well more
or less same story we are going to
capture on g6 pawn captures g6 Queen to
c2 King to f7 and now the strong reply
Knight captures defy again and again if
Bishop to d6 then our knight can come
back and what is a healthy pawn up and
if he captured on defy then white can
get the similar sequence that is Bishop
captures defy King to e7 Queen to e4
check King to d6 and Bishop captures b7
last but not least I think at 6 is
probably the safest option here for the
black but still after the move Knight
captures g6 pawn captures g6 and the
Muji Phi it is only white who is going
to have all the fun in this line we are
following a game between two freedom
master where black continue with pawn
captures G Phi pawn captures g5 rook
captures h1 Bishop captures h1 and black
has a three location for the night but
again it doesn't matter wherever it goes
white response is very much crushing in
the game black plays Knight to g8 wear
white responds with the mood defy
and you can see the easiest attacking
scheme by wide he wants to play Quinn 2d
3d for blast open the center and get a
great advantage and funny now black
cannot do anything about it for example
in the game black continue with Knight
to c6 e for happen on the ball so three
times attacking on d5 so black plays D
captures e4 counter attacking on d4 but
this is just an illusion as after Bishop
captures evil there's a potent threat of
Bishop captures g6 which black defended
with Knight G to e7 so Holliday black
has a pathetic pawn structure on the
Kings side and on top of everything
after the move Bishop to e3 white
maintained his decent advantage okay
Queen to d7 very obvious black wants to
castle on the Queen side but white
simply doesn't allow him so he continued
with a very energetic play defy
attacking the knight and after the
following sequence that is he captures
d5 Knight captures defy if black castles
the Knight to e7 is a very strong reply
so black continued with Knight captures
defy Queen captures defy Queen captures
defy Bishop captures defy castle on the
Queen side attacking the bishop and
after White Castle on the Queen side you
can easily see that not only white
obtain a to Bishop which already
threatening some nasties but in a long
run because black has this double
isolated pawn it is only white who is
playing for the win I have attached rest
of the game in the PGN which will show
you how easily White has won this game
that's a guy
I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful tricky line in the opening
play the move g4 at this position shock
your opponent and grab some exciting
victories thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care